And then introduce the
Alright. Welcome everyone to the
DDPS seminar. Before we
introduce our invited speaker,
let's go over some rules and
logistics. First of all, please
mute yourself during the talk.
On this you have questions. If
you have questions, you're
welcome to unmute and ask. As
otherwise, please use chatroom
to post your questions so that
we can address them in the q&a
session at the end. Second,
today's GDPs seminar is open to
external audiences. So no
classified discussion. And
finally, the talk today will be
recorded and uploaded in our
YouTube channel about it. Now,
let me introduce our speaker
today it is an honor to host in
Lyon, with a call a visiting
assistant professor of
Mathematics at the Department of
Mathematics of Purdue
University. She earned her PhD
degree in mathematics from the
Chinese University of Hong Kong
in 2021. On the supervision of
Professor Jun Zhao, abroad
research area is in
computational and applied
mathematics. Her current
research interests include ill
posed inverse problems, machine
learning, numerical methods for
partial differential equations
and scattering theory. Today in
we'll talk about data assisted
algorithms for inverse random
source scattering problems.
Please enjoy and except a
wonderful talk. Now without
further ado, let me pass the
baton to Ian by asking one
random question as usual,
today's random question is,
where is your favorite place in
the world?
Well, third place if you don't
specify the location for this,
of course, we'll be home with my
loved ones. As long as it says
my loved ones is a home that no
matter where it is, on Valencia
mentioning a lot location, the
city, Maggie Hong Kong at this
moment.
Hong Kong is a nice city. I've
been there once. All right,
stage is yours.
I'm not sure screen. Okay, first
of all, Sam is standing next to
us. So for your kind invitation
and introduction. So, as just as
I just mentioned, I'm a second
year postdoc at Purdue
University right now. And the
one I'm very glad to be able to
share with you our latest work
on data assisted algorithms for
inverse random sauce problems.
This is a joint work with
Professor Jung, Hwan and
pitching linguist who is who I'm
currently working with Al
Purdue. Now, I will start with a
brief overview of what I will be
talking about in the next 45
minutes. We are interested in
the inverse random source
problem. So generally speaking,
is A inverse problem. And for
inverse problems, mathematically
speaking, we try to determine
the unknown coefficients in a
partial differential equation,
whereas the exterior
measurements, this could be
explained with this diagram
here. Now, if you're interested
in certain physical phenomenon,
and it could be modeled by a
partial differential equation,
then the physical properties of
that media will go into this
partial differential equation as
some coefficients in that
equation. Now, if you have the
equation have the coefficients
that you need, you can
numerically solve it with FANUC
unmanned phantom volume
difference, and after solving
it, you have the numerical
solution to that equation. Now,
the thing I just described is
what we call the racks problem,
we simulate something solve for
solution. The corresponding
inverse problem will be you
don't know about the physical
products, you don't know the
information about the medium,
and but you have the exterior
measurement of the quantity
which is the solution of the
direct problem. And with this
exterior measurement, and our
understanding of that partial
differential equation, we trying
to reconstruct that physical
property of our interest. Now,
this figure on the right hand
side is one device for solving
the inverse problems. That's the
electrical impedance tomography
COVID is a medical imaging type
of problem. We attached current
around the human body, we inject
currents, we attach to this
Black Scholes inject currents
from this electrodes and then we
will measure the voltage induced
by the current. And, of course,
this would be, we don't want to
include that measurement in this
case, right. So with the
boundary measurement, we will be
able to reconstruct the medium
coefficient inside the human
body, this is governed by some
elliptic equation. That's one
concrete example of inverse
problem. Now, the difficulty of
solving inverse problem, there
are several, typical difficult
that is, the first one will be,
it's possible that given the
measurements of the solution
that we collect, you cannot unit
determine the physical property.
And another thing is that it's
possible that this inversion
this reconstruction is very
unstable. If you have little
noise, a little perturbation on
the measurement measurement you
collect, we will get very
different or reconstructed
coefficient, that's not
something we want, because the
noise in measurement are not
avoidable. And also in your
class large scale computations,
you might need to compute some
large scale problems, or you
need to repeat it slowly. So
being the direct problem to get
a good reconstruction, and also,
of course, and certainly, like
you cannot say for sure that you
have an accurate model, and you
cannot make sure that you don't
have uncertainty from the
environment. These are the
possible difficulties when
solving an inverse problem. Now,
when it comes to our problem,
the inverse source problem,
there exists some traditional
methods to solve it, that is
purely based on the physical
path, the understanding of the
differential equations. If we
want to reconstruct this target
source distribution, or the left
hand side, the reconstruction we
get with the traditional mess,
would be like this is actually
an acceptable reconstruction,
because I need to emphasize that
the measurement we have will be
the just exterior, maybe on the
surface of a certain domain. So
it's not an easy problem. And
this type of reconstruction is
already quite well, you can tell
tell that there are sort of
circles, it's just that it's not
overly accurate. Although
traditional method works, there
are several limitations, like it
only works for certain cases.
And I will explain when it
works, and when it won't work in
the following sections. But it
has several limitations. And, of
course, we want to have a more
accurate reconstruction. That's
when we consider can we use some
data assisted approach to tackle
this difficulties. And that's
why we propose a two stage data
assisted method for the first
stage, we use some method
inspired by the traditional
ones, we use the physical
information to from the boundary
measurement, we get some
approximation of the coefficient
and in the second stage, now,
from the approximation to the
exact coefficient, it becomes an
image to image types problem.
Now, this is a widely started
topic in computer vision. And
that gave us the that means we
have different algorithms that
we can try, if that will improve
the approximation. And we
compare the performance of
principal component analysis
based regression or Islam, your
net based regression picks two
picks, and there's different
types of neural networks. I will
further explain this figures in
the numerical experiments part,
but is this just a compilation
of the reconstruction using
different types of data assisted
algorithms as the second stage?
Physical best numerical model is
accurate and justified, because
we know that model, but they may
not be available as if we have
some constraints that whether
you can use the traditional
method or not. And data can be
appropriately incorporated to
address this difficult that is,
and how to combine traditional
methods and a data driven method
is an important research
question. And machine learning
techniques in computer vision
are useful for imaging problems,
especially for the image to
image tasks. With this
operations will propose our
method which successfully
combined the physical
information and the data we
have.
So now, let's
get started going to details
about this board that I've
mentioned. Now, the first
question was out The scattering
problems the inverse random
source problem and the title is
one of inverse scattering
problem scattering problem
concern the interaction between
waves and medium wave
propagation happens everywhere,
we could be talking about
acoustic waves, electromagnetic
waves, elastic waves, etc. I'm
talking now the source of some
acoustic waves, and use the
light everywhere light
electromagnetic waves, and the
settings may like this, you have
a point source access here, it
will induce some electrical like
electric field with noted by E,
when that electric field of
field propagates, it could
interact with something like
this that will be offset ago, it
may not penetrate this obstacle.
So, we need to add some boundary
condition around it. And the web
will propagate and it will cross
this interface as and it must
have different medium
coefficients above and below us.
So, the wolfelt, of course,
become different. And this
process like, Oh, if we know
about words, source know the
obstacle, now the interface,
then solving for the wavefield
II, that's the direct problem.
And the corresponding inverse
problem will be maybe we don't
know where is that source or
maybe we don't know where is
that of circle but we have the
measurement of the Winfield e
around this plane gamma one,
then we'll try to reconstruct to
recover was a source for where
we are as an obstacle or the
shape of this interface as that
will be England's problem. Now,
inverse scattering problem can
be categorized, insert into
three types. The first class
will be inverse medium problems.
It's widely used for geophysical
evaluation, seismic imaging,
actual sound tomography or
biomedical images. If we are
considering this type of
applications, we have our GM
here the SYNACK upon sauce that
will be acoustic with and we can
measure from the hydrophones
here, measure the wavefield then
we want to surf the waves
propagate along all the three
layers of mediums, and we want
to recover the medium
coefficients of this medium that
will tell us the progress of
this mediums. Another type
inverse of circle problems is
for ridden sonar, submarine
detection, non destructive
testing, remote sensing, etc.
This stimulus setting as the
previous one, we still have a
ship here we want to, we still
measure the wellfield above the
sea and we want to recover the
shape of the seafloor, that
seafloor tomography. Now this
time we're interested in that
surface. And the last class will
be inverse solve problem that is
the type of problems we mainly
focus on in this work. Inverse
source problems are used for
medical imaging, antenna design
and synthesis. This two figures
illustrate the Ameche
tomography, which is another
type of medical tomography
problems, we have a device like
this and we will collect the
electromagnetic field around the
head. And with when we recover
the source that induce the
electromagnetic field that we
measured, we will know the top
versus source how that is
distributed, will give us the
give the doctor the information
to tag on last certainly there
is. Now, still one ingredient in
the title that I haven't
mentioned, that's randomness,
where needs to take randomness
into consideration, in a sense
that inverse problems can
involve uncertainties due to the
unpredictability of the
environment, incomplete
knowledge of the system, random
noise of the measurements, or
fine scale fluctuation in
simulation. That, again, as I'm
talking I'm the source of
acoustic word, but they're also
our conditioner or refrigerator
near me, they're also making
some they're also sauce and
they're the noise. A component
might um combinate the sauce
that we want to reconstruct. So
the unpredictability of the
environment needs to be
considered and it will goes into
the differential equation,
things will become a stochastic
differential equation. And
here's a list of several of
incompressible based off
researchers while working on the
inverse problems involving
randomness, and increasing
interest in both theoretical and
numerical status of the random
inverse problems now, I really
need to show some partial
differential equations. Now,
inverse random solves problems
and our consideration is
governed by this stochastic
impulse equation. So, Sam Haas
equation comes from the wave
equation is a time harmonic form
of the wave equation, and that
is to model the acoustic wave or
electromagnetic waves in certain
constraints. Now, for this
equation that you denotes, the
wave field that we can measure
will fill you and this callback
denotes the wave number, it's a
constant positive number related
to the property of the
wellfield. This EDA, it reflects
the property of any homogeneous
medium, it's a function can base
different value at different
location. And rather than set F
is the source that induce such a
field when there's ads this one
line which are called Somerfield
radiation condition, to ensure
that this direct problem has a
unique solution, that's it, we
know kappa will knock it out,
we're not f solving for that
wolfelt u is a well posed
problem when this Sommerfeld
relation condition, it basically
tells us that when the welfare
propagates far away from the
origin, it will decay in a
certain rate. Now stochastic
part comes from the source if
the source arm if we model it as
a random function driven by an
additive wise noise. That is, as
is equal to a deterministic
function g plus deterministic
function edge times the what's
nice. Here G and H are two
deterministic global functions
and need to advertise that if
the right hand side is only a
deterministic function, then the
problem is well started that
direct problem is a common one.
But if we add a whatnots to it,
the all the previous theoretical
results need to be checked
again, because we don't even
have a weak solution to this
equation. And we all have the
mouth solution, but the truth we
can justify that it has a
continuous modification. The
related regularity results as
shown in this to work. Now
correspond the inverse problem.
If we have measurements of this
irradiated will filter you on
the boundary of the ball with
this are at fan that many with
numbers, we want to recover the
statistic properties of the
source. That is we want to
recover the average G and the
variance at school. Now, the
problem, although this looks
like it's a simple equation, but
different cases for the
reconstruction related to this
medium coefficient either, we're
not going going to reconstruct
this either, but it will cause a
difference when we do the
reconstruction. If this either
equal to zero, that is
homogeneous media and our
consideration is the rather easy
problem. And for the second
case, this data is not equal to
zero, but we know that
distribution of data then this
is a slot. This is a more
difficult question to answer.
Can we recount work F. And for
the circus, we know that Ada is
not equal to zero, but we don't
know the distribution of ADA
that is we have unknown
inhomogeneous media, can we
recover F
for this circus is there there
exists previous methods for some
of them, Okay, this one we have
homogeneous made. The way to
tackle it is to formulate it as
an integral equation and use
Cosmos method to to reconstruct
the source. But second case, it
another equal to zero, but we
know the distribution, we can
solve an eigenvalue problem and
then use Cosmos muscle to
reconstruct it. For circuits.
That's an open problem. Like we
have either we don't we don't
know either. We don't know
source, and we don't know source
is how to recover that source as
a result, the information of the
media and that's where our
muscles would work. Now, because
as I mentioned, the tradition In
a mask, further case one will
become the first stage of our
product method we proposed. So,
we are, for the next section, I
will give you a detailed
explanation about how the first
how the traditional method works
for the first case. Now,
solution to that hamotzi
equation with homogeneous Smith
have this type of solution
formula that you execute
solutions will be represented
with this integral of small g
and capital G and this integral
between the bass noise and
fundamental solution G is a
fundamental solution in two
dimensional case it will be
handled function. Next, we can
take expectation and variance on
both sides of this solution
formula and fix the real politic
as the first line takes the
imaginary part forgets the
second line, take variance from
both sides and detox the
imaginary part from the real
part we get the third line. Now,
for this three equations, the
same I colored as blue will be
the micro we can take
measurements throughout this
wave field and the same colored
right. The other sense we want
to reconstruct. So, all three
equations can be represented as
an operator equation that AJ
represented rather than that
this integral operators we have
polar information about the
kernel of them. The reason why I
need to do this detection, this
combination of the low part and
the imaginary part of the virus
is that this one has is this,
this battery discretize this
power to get a better post ha it
has singular value decays more
slowly than with a single
imaginary or single real part.
Now, not forget about the PDE.
Now, we are just recovering this
unknown G or H which is a cue
here, from the measurement of
the boundary data with finite
many different boom numbers TJ,
recover Q from P, that's a
sampling our trapo loss right.
Now, we're going to use the
regularized block Kosmos method
to solve it. And so the inner
iteration will do this type of
update. And this could be
illustrated with this diagram
here was initial gas Q zero, we
projected onto the solution
playing corresponding to the
first operator quotient integral
operator equation, and then we
project it to the second
solution hyperplane. And to the
third, do this iteratively
initially, eventually, it will
converge to the solution we
want. That's the regularized
Cosmos message. Here we add this
gamma as a regularization
parameter. Because this AJ AJ
star is still your post your
conditioned matrix. Now, I've
been talking about this
tradition of muscle the
limitations to it, as I
mentioned. Recall, recall that
this PJ what we call the
measurement comes from the left
hand side of this equation, we
need to take expectation and
variance of the measurements
were collected. And this could
be achieved by taking a lot of
realizations and use the sample
mean, right? That means there's
no way that you can get a great
approximation with without a
large number of realizations,
actually, more than one solid
realizations are needed to
reconstruct the average and even
more to achieve satisfied
reconstruction of the variance.
And here is some figures to
illustrate this facts. This is
the root cause to target we want
to reconstruct the source we
want and this is the
reconstruction with 10
globalization, this is with 100
this one with one solid
realizations. And you can see
that we have to use enough
realization to gather
satisfactory reconstruction. And
secondly, the sequence qk we get
from Cosmos maths, it will
converge to a minimum norm
solution, which is quite blurry.
So one here, it's quite blurry.
And moreover, forecasts are a
when you don't know the
distribution of the medium, then
you can't do out the integral
equation L here this AJ comes
from this right hand side. This
comes from the fundamental
solution, but how to have
information of the A partial
differential equation to write
down the mental solution. And
when we have no information
about the medium, this can't be
derived. And we have some more
theoretical results. Related to
this limitations, if we use
Cosmos muscles to find the limit
of that q q k and the arrow for
each iteration between the
iteration and the minimum norm
solution we want can be
decomposed into the noise arrow
and iteration arrow, the
iteration arrow will decay when
you have more and more
iterations, but the nice arrow
according to our analysis, here,
it will have an upper bound and
this upper bound is proportional
to k, which means, if you have
noise in your mesh measurements,
this PJ it will actually
increasing when you do more and
more iterations. And this
coincide with our numerical
results. Like if you use Cosmos,
where you do more and more
iteration, the measurements
will, the noise in the
measurement will deteriorate
your reconstruction. So, that's
why it comes to a lot of
iterations. So, our observation
will be like this, this thing I
just mentioned, those physical
best numerical model is indeed
accurate and justified, but they
may not be available for certain
cases, like if we don't have
information about the medium,
and also the data can be, but we
know that data can be
appropriately incorporated to
address this difficulties. So
now let's consider if machine
learning techniques could help
with this reconstruction. And
the physical information that we
have could help us to give us a
trap prayer or in short, in
short distribution of the data
are used for the training the
second stage. Now, we'll talk
about using your natural
techniques for direct and
inverse problems. A simple
approach a direct approach would
be taking the measurement as
input, take the unknown
parameter as output, train the
neural network in a regression
manner, and know that this is
not going to work very well. As
I mentioned, the measurement
will collect on the boundary of
survey of the of the domain and
the unknown distribution unknown
parameter Why is in the whole
domain is that you're using a
one dimensional data to
reconstruct a two dimensional
reconstruction. If you treat it
as a blackbox, there's not
likely it's not likely that you
can success in the recover in
the reconstruction process. So,
there have been other attempts
for the inverse scattering
problems. Your we just list for
this is just an incomplete list,
people try to combine the
physical information and data in
different ways. And I also need
to mention that there are a
number of muscles to use the
neural network to solve the
forward problem to solve the PDE
there are also useful to us for
inverse problem, because
traditional way to solve inverse
problem will be casted into a
minimization problems and to
solve the minimization problem,
you need to repeatedly solve the
direct problem and this no
network related algorithm will
accelerate this process. And
also to learn that mapping is
also kind of 1111 of the
operator learning for us as
software owner operator and some
other acrosomal also works
pretty good for this type of
problems. And our muscles is
different from the previous
mentioned once in a sense that
we use the physical information
in the first stage and to and
use the neural network the image
to image type of algorithm for
the second stage.
Not in the first stage, we will
use the thing we just mentioned,
the cosmos algorithm for the
integral equation, getting that
TJ the measurements, we don't do
a lot of iterations okay,
because the more iteration you
do the, the larger the noise
level noise error will become.
So just through several
iterations to get an
approximation to 00. Now we get
the image. So for the second
stage, we learn the mapping
between the approximation image
t zero to the exact G
approximated x zero to the exact
match with the different math
algorithms for the image to
image type of problems. And what
has to This are four different
types of algorithms for the
second stage, the first one will
be the principal component
analysis based regression with
some second one based
compensation or Koopman operator
tap, third one be the unit based
regression gruesome and the
first one will be it picks two
picks your network for the first
two of them, we basically just
first carry out the dimension
reduction and then we have the
input and output space and then
apply linear regression that
different in the sense that the
was different way to do the
dimension reduction. And you can
imagine that third and the
fourth one related to neural
network works much better than
the previous two linear
regression type. So, I will
mainly focus on the third and
the fourth one explain a little
bit about how they actually
works. Now, you net best
regression to be explained with
this diagram, unit based neural
network the encoder decoder
architecture like this now, from
here to here from the
measurement to the input image,
that's where we use the kosmos
muscles for the integral
equation. Once you get after
several iterations, you get a
approximation image here from
this image to this image, your
will be contracting paths and
expansion expensive paths. And
for each block we have this
convolution plus convolution
layer batch normalization and
riilu layer, the difference
between this unit and the
traditional convolutional neural
network will be we have this
state connection here.
Therefore, we can preserve the
features of the input image with
this skip connections, the
feature maps are passed to the
corresponding layer in the
expensive parts where the skip
connections and this is widely
used muzzle photo medical
imaging to do the segmentation
for the training process, we
will minimize this error one
arrow as the loss function not
the false algorithm will be
fixed takes algorithm is
conditional generative
adversarial neural network could
be illustrated with this diagram
for the gang type of neural
network we need to train the
generator and the discriminator
which are two neural networks
jointly the input of the
generator will be the image and
output of the generator will be
also image input of the
discriminator will be power of
image and output output will be
a scalar between zero and one.
And that jointly trained in the
competitive manner as the
generator wants to generate the
image resemble the target
coefficient and the
discriminator will attempt to
differentiate between the real
powers and the generated past by
real powers will mean the past
coming from the training data
and generated pass means that
this x and the output of the
generator this house will be
able to call sick powers. This
objective can be achieved by
dealing with this loss function.
The this is a binary cross
entropy type the generator will
try will be trained to minimize
this one and the discriminator
trains to maximum this one is a
conditional Gann we need to add
another term this term is about
the is the loss terms for the
generator because we want the
generator to sample the arm to
mimic the exact coefficient. Now
in the pics to pics algorithms,
the generators architecture will
be again the unit and the patch
gang will be used as the
discriminator. Now finally,
let's present the miracle
experiments. For the trainees
that we have 2000 samples each
with three cylinder inclusions,
which are randomly sampled the
position radius and magnitude
are randomly sampled. The
measurements we have will be the
same static data of 100
realizations of average
reconstruction. And when it one
southern realizations for
various reconstruction this is
this is already one tense of the
relation realization needed for
satisfactory reconstruction both
traditional method and the
measurement will be measured as
throught 32 uniform distributed
points on the circle. Now the
source will be the swath of
source volume we're seeing This
square and we have measurements
along this circle at so two
point and we have five, we have
numbers. Now, some numerical
results, this the the average
reconstruction in the
homogeneous medium from left to
right, we have thus the exact
source that we want to
reconstruct the outrage of the
source. Second column is the
cosmos reconstruction, the thing
we get from the first stage self
column will be the PCA based
regression results. Post column
will be the Copeland BMD tab
reconstruction. And this one
from units, this column from the
pics topics algorithm, we can
observe that from here from the
left to right, we get more and
more complicated model, but we
get better and better
reconstruction. We'll have a
table here. Like for the
training time PC and Copeman we
use we meet last time and for
unit and picks two picks. When
you choose 7075 minutes,
somebody five seconds and more
than 10 minutes for pics to pics
does the relative error of the
case in this manner, but we will
say that pics to pics actually
have a slightly larger relative
error compared with units. But
if you tell from the image,
you'll see that is actually gave
us all batters give us a sharper
edge. Now, this is a variance
reconstruction, the
reconstruction of edge square is
this, this is a rather powder
problem. And we have to find
those same observation from the
left to right, we'll get better
and better reconstruction and
same observation here from the
relative L one arrow. Now, these
are experiments for case three.
Recall that case three is when
you don't know about the media,
how to the reconstruction of the
source and the not existing
traditional muscle force. But
this is our reconstruction. The
first two rows are about our
reconstruction. And these two
rows about the various
reconstruct this is average this
for veterans from the left to
right, we do get better and
better at construction. If you
compare this figure with the
previous figure, it will say
that's the cause master
construction, the same we get
from the first stage this are
much worse than the previous
ones, because we don't actually
know the exact model because we
don't know the model. But the
first stage is based on the
fundamental solution of the
homogeneous. So there's but
still even with a much worse
initial condition, the with the
help of this data assist
algorithm we get ready good
reconstructions. Now, this is a
generalization test. Recall that
for the training data set, we
use the three inclusions type
the cylinder inclusions, and if
we test our result for the last
year, we have five center
inclusions, and from the this
row, we have those simplified
font on top, we have ellipse,
insights, little ellipse shaped
inclusions, still get pretty
good reconstructions.
Okay, and here I conclude with
some ongoing and future work. As
I mentioned, there are all
different types of scattering
problems. And the inverse source
problem we just mentioned is
actually linear taps. And here
we consider the inverse of
circle problems, that is this
differential equation under
consideration, we want to
recover the shape of this B. And
this is a clearly nonlinear
problem. And this is the
reconstruction we have we also
use some some traditional muscle
not integral correlation, but
some direct probing tap with,
with the measurements we
collect, we could get this type
of reconstruction from the
traditional method, then we'll
learn the mapping from this one
to the exact coefficient and
this is a reconstruction we can
get with with the same amount of
training data and we can see
that the only difference between
the extract of circle
distribution and reconstruction
we get and some other ongoing
work will be the theoretical
analysis for the stability
estimate for this type of
immerse random source problems
which are off grid off grid
theoretical interest And here
are some references for the
works that I've just mentioned.
Okay, then that's all I need to
talk about. Thanks for being
here.
Okay, thank you so much for the
wonderful talking. Very nice
result. Very impressive results.
All right, so let's have a q&a
sessions. Anyone who has
questions, you can unmute
yourself and then ask questions.
I guess while you're preparing
your questions I can ask
question here. So if you go back
to slide 28, I believe. So
there's a the comparison of the
results will be, you know, among
four different the data driven
approach data assisted approach.
Here, you said the time of the
unit is 74, and picks two picks
is seven 200 729. That's the
training time. Yeah, that's for
training. And when you do the
training, I assume you use a lot
of data. Yeah. In supervised
manner. Yeah. And once you are
done with the training, you
know, actual, this predictions
were evaluation of that. The
source locations were the source
times. It's it. It's very fast,
right?
Yeah. Testing takes no time.
Like, for the first stage, yes,
you still need to do the Cosma.
But it takes not comparable to
the training time. And when the
second stage, you already gets
the train network. So takes no
time.
Yeah, so I mean, looks like
there is an offline and online.
Yeah. Yeah. Where you can
collect the data from that a
physics based inverse problem?
Yeah. And you match those with a
known source arms. And that you
train the unit and picks two
picks. And once that is done,
you can try that on to new
source transferred. Because
there is a two stages, the first
stage, you still have to solve
inverse problem, you know, in
traditional way, right? Yeah,
that takes time.
Yeah, that takes takes a little
time, because it's a solving. So
basically, we just solve this
equation, right? And we solve it
with Cosmos, if we only do
several iterations, then this
thing takes takes no time,
because this is not really that
large.
Is not that large. How does the
size of a determines
now. So for example, here, we
have in our look at Psalm 64
times 64 pixels. So the inputs
of this, this matrix will be
this Q That's from the unknown G
or H. So it will have 64 times
64 as the as the the, the one
side of the matrix, and for
another part lb, PJ, that's a
boundary measurement. So that
would be 64 times four, one. And
that's what that's from the
boundary measurement when use
our 32 measures points. So
that's actually just sort of
certitude.
Okay. And the A matrix here is
dense matrix. So
it will be with these types of
pronouns. So
yes, it's a data matrix. Yeah.
So the if the pixel size is
bigger, that dense matrix
becomes bigger. Yeah, I guess.
As long as we deal with a two
dimensional image, I guess it we
can handle that.
The other difficulty also lies
in the power involved. Like for
each sample, we need 100 or 100
lactations for each realization
Ewing to solve the forward
problem once so for each sample,
you need to solve it 1000 times.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, that's a problem. Yeah.
Yeah.
Well, that's the problem of any
data driven approach. generating
data is not an easy task. All
right. Sounds good. Is there any
questions from audiences?
Audience?
While it's not, I have one more
question. So if you can clarify,
you know, how you apply the
Kumaun. Time, mon type, data
assisted methods. So PCA, it's
clear to me, you do some sort of
SVD?
Yeah, yeah. So, for PCA, yeah,
we listed we just brought them
as vectors and concatenates, the
two beds for pizza, you just do
it separately, do the SVD
decomposition for the input
image, list it once. They said,
so for matrix and we severally,
do SVD for the output image
once. And we need use that use
sigma waiting conversation with
the new the redacted dimension
redacted, new eight will be you
transpose the data and b and
sigma inverse from the other
from the difference? of the
foot?
Yeah, that is, to me, but the
common man type? Oh, yeah. You
come up with some linear
operator? Right? Yeah, that's
once and that's why I have a
little bit doubt about how to
say it and the name of this
algorithm we do. So we don't
actually have the dynamic
system. Yeah. But we're just,
there's just one staff dynamic
system from from from like, here
to here. So we just see it as a
one step dynamic system.
Okay, and then you have a bunch
of different the previous step,
and then, you know, next step,
and you just pair them. Yeah,
come up with the approximate
linear operator. That's, that's
what you do with a man operator?
Okay. Got it. Okay. Have you
have you tried, you know,
completely getting rid of the
physics, the first stage,
that will be that will be very
hard, that will be very hard to
try any luck to start with, if
you don't use the first stage,
what you have is the just, I
don't have the figures showing
the solution. But if you have
this type of source, the
solution will be the oscillating
with distribution. And what you
have is only the source, there
will be a circle when measured
around the circle, it will be
just a curve, even if you have
five curves, because we will
have five real numbers is how to
get from the curve to the whole
interior distribution. Is that
dimension salt match?
I see. All right. Okay, we have
a question from outro. Do you
wanna unmute and ask? Yes.
Actually, the first stage was
you do three iteration iterative
solution. How do you select
stopping criterion? How to
decide when to stop iterations?
Yeah, that's a great question is
how to decide because we have
some sort of radical result here
that it sucks because the noise
comes from the measurements
noise and also the error of the
P comes from the mean value
mean? sample mean is so it's
unavoidable so it will increase
the noise will increase. So it's
hard to decide. So eventually,
we decided just to do
fabrication for five iterations
and stop and that's why you
don't have a very good
reconstruction here but it's not
guaranteed that you do more
iteration you will get a better
one it might get even worse
reconstruction choice just
beside to always that real
steps. Once you get reasonable
initial approximation, we stop
Could you please show that slide
to is Liam
Say that again?
Could you please show the slide
when you which bounce your URL
reconstruct? No, no, not
previous previous videos
somewhere in the beginning at
The beginning
your show to just recently, when
I asked you about
a slide, I picked him up middle
as the sun goes up the error is
increased.
Yeah, that's in that here. Yeah.
So, totally to this day you have
two Sigma Gamma here, which is
which?
Yeah, this Sigma Gamma is
related is the smallest nonzero
singular value of this operator
comes from the. So it's all
these metrics that are related
to something about the current
chair and chair that delta
gamma, this one is top with a
nod to the Alto arrow. So this
one is fixed, we know that it
exists.
know a little bit distant system
system of equations. So the J is
your data, right? P J,
S comes from our measurement
data. Yeah, so p j
is just one data point. It's a
scalar. Right? To check it Oh,
it's
from here. So vector after this
growth has so back to black so
the two by one
vector. Okay, so Okay, so it's
vector one position, okay. And Q
is your image right?
Here is us our q is our image
that we want. So
basically, a j is your operator,
like three dimensional operator,
which maps two dimensional image
to one dimensional vector?
Right. Correct. Thank you. Thank
you very much. Very interesting.
Thank you.
I agree. It's a very interesting
work. Any other question?
Well, if not, let's thank our
speaker in half for the
wonderful talk. Yeah, thank you
so much, saying thank you. And
after this talk, hopefully, you
know, you know, fruitful
collaborations will set up and,
yeah, let's hope for that. Okay.
Thank you. And thank you,
everyone.